are hurting canadians
whether they're in ottawa windsor
coots or emerson
they're endangering jobs
their threats to our economy and to
public safety
the blockades are hurting small
businesses and neighborhoods
at the border they're impacting trade
supply chains and manufacturing
the people these blockades are hurting
our everyday families
auto assembly workers farmers
truckers
and blue-collar canadians
this morning i spoke with david cassidy
of unifor
who told me how badly
this is hurting workers in southern
ontario we both agree that blockades are
unacceptable
that they have to end
for the good of all canadians
yes
foreign
yesterday with mayor drew dilkins of
windsor to offer the full and continued
support of the federal government
minister al capra as well as ministers
blair mendicino and leblanc
are also in regular contact with their
counterparts
ontario's announcement this morning is
responsible and necessary
we will continue working alongside all
partners to get the situation under
control
this morning i had a
direct call with president biden to talk
about our shared challenges at the
border
i updated him on the situation
particularly in windsor
we discussed the american and indeed
global influences on the protest
we talked about the us-based flooding of
the 9-1-1 phone lines in ottawa the
presence of u.s citizens in the
blockades
and the impact of foreign money to fund
this illegal activity
president biden and i both agree that
for the security of people and the
economy
these blockades cannot continue
so make no mistake
the border cannot and will not remain
closed
i want to remind everyone
that politicians don't direct police in
a democratic society but i can assure
you that the rcmp is working with
provincial and local police departments
to enforce the law
everything is on the table
because this unlawful activity has to
end
and it will
end
of course
i can't say too much more now as to
exactly when or how this ends because
unfortunately we are concerned about
violence so we're taking every
precaution to keep people safe
but the absolute
safest way for this to end
is for everyone to return to your
communities
now
if you're still participating in illegal
blockades
you're hurting your neighbors
so it's time to go home
especially
if you have kids with you
danny
[Music]
is
regulations and practices that ensure
funds cannot be used for criminal act or
illegal activity and these blockades
are illegal
canadian banks are monitoring financial
activity very closely and taking action
as necessary
i want to make something very clear
the illegal blockades seeking to take
our neighborhoods and our economy
hostage
and the collective coveted fatigue we
are facing
are two very separate things
if you joined the protests because
you're tired of covin
you now need to understand
you're breaking laws
the consequences are becoming more and
more
severe you don't end up losing your
license
end up with a criminal record which will
impact your job
your livelihood
even your ability to travel
internationally including to the u.s
we've heard your frustration with covid
with the measures that are there to keep
people safe
we've heard you
it's time to go home now
and to the people who are tired of this
pandemic
that is all canadians
i want you
to be able to get back to the things
that you love
i hear you all of you
parliamentarians hear it in their
communities we all hear it from friends
and family
from people like laurie from here in
ontario who wrote to me to say she
disagrees with the bad behavior of the
blockaders
she's also tired of the restrictions
or helen from toronto who's worried
about what the restrictions are doing to
children's mental health
i understand
we don't want these measures to last
longer than they should
and we never did
but the truth is
because of
all of our efforts
we saved more lives in canada
than in many other countries
we helped people like samuel from
courtney bc who also wrote to tell me
that as a healthcare worker our measures
are keeping him safe
is
foreign
and what's best
to protect canadians
i have multiple meetings every week to
talk about what the next step are
this morning for example
i spoke with dr tam and minister duklow
among others
about the plan to adjust travel measures
under federal jurisdiction
as canadians
it's important to continue
being there for one another
we're fighting a virus we're not
fighting each other
people are making sacrifices and have
been for the past two years
it's never the time
to hurt our economy and fellow canadians
with illegal blockades but especially
not now
after all we've sacrificed together
after all we've done
to get back to the things we love
and reopen our lives
during the summit with president biden
and allies we discussed the importance
of finding a peaceful solution that
remains our focus
we're all concerned
that russia is continuing to build up
its truth presence
and looking actively for excuses to act
instead
russia must de-escalate
the west is standing firm together
coordinated and ready to impose severe
costs including sanctions
if russia
invades ukraine once again
we're also strengthening our support and
presence through nato
we will continue
to support ukraine democracy
sovereignty and independence and
more than anything else
continue to support the people of
ukraine
this is an evolving situation but the
bottom line is this
we're not seeking confrontation with
russia
but we're resolved
to stand firm with the ukrainian
people's right
to determine their own future
merciful
thank you prime minister melcy from
muniz we will now begin with 20 minutes
of questions starting with 10 minutes
from the room
followed by 10 minutes by the phone
will come outside
over the top
hello prime minister mike blanchfield
canadian press it's been two weeks and
only now is the ontario government
taking concrete steps until now your
government
has simply said you'll continue to
provide resources when asked
so why has it taken
two weeks 15 days
for any government anywhere to do
something directly to address this
crisis now
from the very beginning we have been
supporting
the ottawa police force and the province
of ontario with any resources they need
to keep public order to
ensure that they're able to move forward
on
ending these blockades i think
citizens of ottawa indeed all canadians
are impatient for them to be done
for people to go home
the message has been clear people have
been heard
in this country jurisdictions work
together
to ensure the right outcomes for
citizens and every step of the way the
federal government has been there
with resources with support
with guidance
and
engagement
that is uh getting us through this one
step at a time
um
me
i know you don't like to talk about your
father's legacy but he faced some
similar decisions in 1970 about the use
of the canadian forces in a civilian law
enforcement capacity you said a moment
ago everything's on the table could you
explain uh to what extent military's
being considered and also
how much did your father's experience
back then color your own reaction to
this and the decision that you may still
have to make
i think
the
as i've said many times my
values are deeply informed by the way
i've brought been brought up not just by
my father but by my experiences as a
canadian i think that's what every
politician brings to bear the core
values that they stand for but every
situation is different what we're seeing
right now is people who are
frustrated deeply
by this unprecedented global pandemic
that has been hitting canadians so hard
over these past two years
leaving people
tired
frustrated angry
wanting it to be done
unfortunately we
know this pandemic doesn't end because
we cross our arms and decide that it's
over
this pandemic will end
by following science
by supporting each other by being there
for each other as canadians have done
throughout these past two years
as a government we made a promise
to have people's backs every step of the
way
that means
doing the things that keep people safe
and supported and get our economy to
come roaring back
as quickly as possible for everyone
and that's why these blockades
that are not helping this pandemic end
any sooner that are hurting our supply
chains hurting families across the
country
endangering our recovery both from the
health crisis and
from the economic crisis
are so wrong and that's why we are going
to continue to use the tools
that we have
as
a society
to ensure that these blockades end and
that starts with local police forces
having the support
of
orders of government of national police
resources
that's how we are getting through this
process
m
foreign
there's an outstanding request from the
ottawa police for 1800 officers until
talking about talking with mayors and
premiers is that supposed to provide
comfort to businesses in centertown that
have been closed for a week
to auto workers who are being laid off
because the ambassador bridge is closed
we have provided hundreds of police
officers uh two jurisdictions that
needed them including ottawa uh the
request for 1600 officers was carefully
examined by
with the opp and experts within the rcmp
leadership to look at what exactly the
plan is what is exactly needed and what
is needed is being provided to be able
to move through this in a peaceful
responsible way but again
the best way to resolve this the best
way to stop hurting
canadian citizens
hard-working canadians across this
country
is for the people in these protests
to understand that they have been heard
but it's time to go home it's time to
bring your kids home from this protest
it is now
in a legal protest
and the consequences on them
and on their families
will be significant if they choose to
continue with this illegal activity
category
is
i've been very very clear
that using
a
military forces against civilian
populations
in canada or in any other democracy
is something to avoid having to do at
all costs
that's why
the solution right now is focused on
police forces
enforcing the laws
that exist
protecting public order in the way that
they are trained to do
in a
predictable
progressive
approach that doesn't skip any steps
that
works to conclude this situation
peacefully
that's why
right now it has become a lot more
difficult and a lot more impactful and
quite frankly expensive
for people who are in those protests
because they're tired of covid
to continue to be part of these illegal
protests the consequences on their lives
for choosing to continue
to endanger the lives and livelihoods of
other canadians
to continue to violate our laws
are going to be more and more extensive
and therefore
we are very hopeful that people will
choose to leave these protests
peacefully now that they've been heard
there are further steps for law
enforcement to take as
that happens or not but we are a long
way
from ever having to call in the military
although of course
we have to be ready for any eventuality
but
it is not something we are seriously
contemplating at this time
uh prime minister i'm wondering if you
have any regrets about the approach that
you've taken to the protesters at any
time especially your comments when they
first arrived do you think that actually
helped or do you think it sort of
angered them and they felt misunderstood
and caused protesters to really dig in
so to speak i think there was a lot of
canadians scratching their heads at the
fact that
um
protesters who
[Music]
purported to speak for truckers
actually didn't represent the 90
of truckers who are vaccinated
i think where
they certainly struck a chord with a lot
of canadians is that people are tired of
covid they're tired of the
restrictions but at the same time as a
government
we made a promise to canadians to have
their backs every step of the way for as
long as it takes and part of having
people's backs
is making sure that the public health
measures that we bring in
the supports for canadians
the supports for provinces that bring in
restrictions
these are the things that get us through
this pandemic these are the things that
save lives
and we are going to continue
to follow the science and do what is
necessary to keep canadians safe every
step of the way because quite frankly
canadians stepped up
90 of canadians got vaccinated
people have been there for each other
they're united in wanting to be there
for each other they're also united and
being sick and tired of this pandemic
those two things can be true and are
true and our responsibility as
orders of government
is to continue to be there for them
every step of the way
[Music]
not only
uh
is
for questions over the phone for ten
minutes
one question one follow-up
for questions over the phone please
press
star one on the device's keypad
the first question is from olivia
stefanovic from cbc news please go ahead
your line is open hi prime minister
trudeau
provinces are listing vaccine passports
and your government as we understand it
is moving to list the pcr testing around
travel are you concerned that the
protesters will claim victory for these
changes and this will embolden them
further
i think different provinces are
taking decisions that they feel are
appropriate to them on vaccine mandates
and restrictions they have in their
jurisdictions
as you know the federal government has
uh responsibility over the borders uh
over uh international travel and over
the federal public service
um
as i said we had uh extensive meetings
today on the next steps that we look
forward to taking and we'll be making
announcements regarding our border
posture next week
are you concerned though that any
announcements you do make could could
leak these protesters claiming victory
and then holding them further
um
i think it's extremely important to
emphasize that all the decisions we take
will be based in science and indeed um
we'll be focused on canadians getting
their lives back to normal
i can emphasize that many of the
measures that we've been talking about
for a long time for example the measures
that canadian the canadian government
brought in
on
needing to be vaccinated to get on a
plane or a train
or needing to be vaccinated to work in
the federal public service are not among
the things that we are considering uh
changing uh we're continuing to look at
the posture to ensure uh that people are
able uh to
get back to the things they love as this
omicron wave begins to recede
thank you
the next question is from mariko walsh
from the global mail please go ahead
your line is open
good afternoon thanks for taking our
questions you spoke briefly at the
beginning about foreign
[Music]
okay
thank you
so the next question will be from the
vic charles from the toronto star please
go ahead
[Music]
that um the promises taken now finally
are possible and necessary
but i want to go back to the question of
why it's taken so long it's been 15 days
what is the border blockages in other
words if the protesters have to work
sorry you were cutting in and out a
little bit uh
tonda can you repeat the end of your
question
did it take so long was this thing only
coordinated in all of your responses
because of the border blockages did that
plastic work
obviously uh the
concern that we're facing on the borders
is at significant we're seeing uh six
different auto plants have to shut down
over the past days because of uh lack of
parts flowing across the ambassador
bridge in windsor we're seeing supply
chains disrupted uh out west because the
foots border chain border crossing uh
and uh in ontario because of the uh the
winds are crossing uh these are things
that we are absolutely taking extremely
seriously but we have been taking the
situation seriously from from the very
beginning and working with partners
municipal and federal to put an end to
these
peacefully and responsibly that is the
job of police police officers and police
forces
the responsibility of politicians is to
ensure
that the police forces have the tools
and the resources they need and that's
what we've been doing but we do not
direct the local police of jurisdiction
uh even uh when they're in proximity to
an international border crossing we all
work together and quite frankly
regardless of the uh
the the the conversations being going on
between jurisdictions i can assure you
that on the ground uh the actual
cohesion and alignment with
all different uh police forces federal
provincial and municipal uh has been
exemplary
paula
what did president biden tell you about
the u.s influence
or participation in the canadian protest
and how will you cut off any foreign
funding
obviously president biden expressed his
concern for the well-being of canadians
and indeed
for the jobs uh and economic ties that
flow back and forth across our border
every single day um
he expressed
concern not just uh for the impacts
right now but at the indication that
there is international support uh from
the united states and from elsewhere
around the world for these protests uh
we've seen uh that the
attack for example on the ottawa 911
system uh came from the united states we
see that almost half of the funding uh
through certain portals that is flowing
to uh the
barricaders here in canada is coming
from the united states we see a
mobilization of
some of the more
challenging political elements in canada
and in the united states around support
for these blockades that are hurting
citizens um we are going to continue to
work together as we have been
on resolving this situation but also on
uh strengthening uh our institutions and
our democratic principles
operator can we go back to marika for a
question
yes thank you
ms walsh if you could press r1 please on
the devices keypad
next question let me collage the globe
and mayo
please go ahead
good afternoon prime minister can you
please provide us with some more details
about the percentage of the fact that
the
federal government believes is coming
from the us
and what percentage of the people in the
crowd are actually americans
those aren't uh details that i have
right in front of me i've heard that on
certain platforms the number of uh u.s
donations are approaching 50 but uh we
can make sure that we uh uh we ensure
that uh that the that information is
shared with you on that uh in terms of
the presence of americans uh in our
protests uh i can assure you that our
police services are monitoring carefully
and
watching and coordinating with partner
agencies around the world
thank you and the u.s has said that it
offers support to the federal government
has the federal government accepted that
support and what specifically is it
um i don't want to get into operational
details but i can assure you that the
conversations directly uh between
governor whitmer of of
michigan and our officials and indeed
with the white house have ensured us of
resources and support if necessary and
the folks on the ground are working out
what is necessary and what could be used
as we move forward
next question
thank you
next question is from justin ling
freelance
please go ahead and zoom in
good afternoon prime minister you've
made it clear that a military option is
the last last last resort um you're
still pleading with them to go home
these protesters have made it clear
they're not leaving they're not
listening to you
they don't really have much interest in
what you have to say so what comes next
what is the next part of the federal
solution here given how overwhelmed the
city of ottawa is
first of all justin i i don't accept uh
the contention that the city of ottawa
has
exhausted its tools and its resources
the ottawa police force has been uh
given resources from both the opp uh and
the and the rcmp
there is uh concerted efforts around
planning and approaches that will
move forward in a proportional way
but i think it is very clear that the
time for these protests to end
has come
people who are there because they're
tired
of covert restrictions we understand
that everyone is tired of covet
restrictions um
but
we need to make sure that our laws are
followed in this country and our laws
will be enforced that's the role of the
ottawa police force that's the role of
police jurisdictions across this country
uh and they will as uh the premier
indicated today uh be enforcing uh
stronger and stronger measures uh that
will make it uh more and more difficult
uh for the protesters to in good
conscience choose to stay part of
illegal protests
follow-up this will be the last question
the prime minister at the top you said
that a more aggressive enforcement
action is right now off the table
because of the risk of violence people
hear that and they get really worried
there's concerns that weapons may be
present in an occupied area there's a
concern about what those orchestras will
do if police try and make a rest do you
have any visibility on that do you have
any indication of exactly what elements
are in that crowd and what potential for
violence there actually is
i can assure you that i have been uh
briefed regularly by both our
intelligence agencies and uh police
agencies on the risk levels to uh
civilians including protesters and
vulnerable people within the protest
there are people who are there with
their kids uh in these protests um and
their well-being is of course top of
mind
for the police services as it is the
well-being of uh citizens in and around
the protests as well who just are trying
to go through their their daily lives
there is always a concern around
escalation the police have a
robust framework within which they go
step by step on making it more and more
uh
difficult for the protests to continue
more and more expensive for people to
choose to stay in the protest both in
ways financial but also on impact of
their lives and livelihood um it is time
for these protesters to go home it is
time to recognize that this protest this
blockade is illegal uh
and uh those consequences on
people choosing to remain uh will be uh
increasingly challenging and the police
have the tools to move forward in a
step-by-step approach that will
bring back order to the city of ottawa
and indeed to our border crossings
now
in our conference
[Music]
hey